welcome back now there's only a couple
of days until MPs vote on Tory's most
brexit deal and the Prime Minister will
be desperately hoping for some new
concessions from Brussels well one man
who's been closer to the negotiations
than most as the former press secretary
Dominic Robb who joins us now live thank
you very much for morning being with us
so we've just heard from Matt Hancock
the house secretary who said that there
is still a chance that the deal could
get through on Tuesday what's your
assessment we'll look I think Matt's
doing a great job there is health
secretary on on the no deal planning as
he described but I think we need to
remember the original deal was voted
down biggest parliamentary defeat in
history 230 votes
Parliament an MP's then supported the
prime minister to go back and make
legally binding changes to the backstop
and support the Malthouse compromise and
what we've seen from the EU is pretty
much total intransigence there was a
tweet by Michel Barnier last night going
back to the very provocative offer to
split up the approach to Northern
Ireland which would threaten the
economic and constitutional integrity of
the UK so I think in the absence of any
change it's difficult to see why the
result on the vote would be different so
you agree with the co-star Milan which
is effectively the deal is exactly the
same as what was put to MPs before well
I want to see whether there's anything
new presented by the Attorney General or
the government there are ongoing
discussions and I you know if there's a
last-minute breakthrough terrific but I
don't see that the deal that failed by
230 votes somehow whistles through
without any meaningful change to it is
it inevitable then that it's gonna lose
I don't think it's inevitable because
the EU could at the eleventh hour said
you know what there's a reasonable ask
here that Parliament's insisted on if
the changes to the backstop we can then
get some close you get this deal done
and move on but the EU needs to move
this is a negotiation and I think it's
interesting that Michele Barney was
going back to an old rejected set of
offers rather than saying okay well
let's try and meet you halfway which is
what normally should happen in a
negotiation so if the deal doesn't go
through then we're expecting to have the
series of votes on whether to leave on
the 29th of March with no deal or
whether to have an extension now I know
that on the show before you said that no
deal is not your preferred outcome so
how would you vote in these potential
votes
oh it's certainly not my preferred
outcome but I think we would build an
the risks of it and that would free us
to grasp the opportunities so you'd
prefer it to an extension which is oh I
think an extension put it this way
none of the challenges or the problems
that we've got now get any better if we
extend and what it will do is embolden
those who frankly want to derail and
frustrate breaks it so I think we should
keep our promises thank you on this
we've legislated so the default position
is that we leave on the 29th of March
preferably with a deal if not on WTO
terms but if that doesn't happen I think
we should keep the promise that every
conservative made in the manifesto that
no deal is better than a bad deal and
some of your colleagues in the concept
of party have rather more should we say
colorful ways of expressing opposition
to an extension we can have a look at
what Steve Baker and Nigel Dodds wrote
in The Sunday Telegraph today the harm
this is about if there was an experience
the harm done to public trust in
politics and democracy itself would be
incalculable for some democracy would be
effectively dead is that right I think
they're absolutely right to talk about
the public frustration and the day of
reckoning that all politicians will have
with the voters if we don't keep our
promises on brexit it was very clear we
would try and get our deal I've always
supported that I supported in the last
series of votes changes to the deal that
would make them acceptable to the UK and
therefore to Parliament in the absence
oh we need to leave on WTO terms and I
believe that we had actually then been a
stronger position after an interim
period to then continue the negotiations
on the longer term relationship with the
EU so should it be whipped then the no
dual vote would you like to see to
resume with it oh we've gap so you've
got to whip the vote to keep our
manifesto pledges okay how can a
government function that doesn't keep
its promises even though she'll lose we
think a few members of her cabinet I
mean it could really split the
Conservative Party
the divisions in the Conservative Party
and indeed in the Labor Party and indeed
in the country a well known but what
people want to see now and the public
overwhelmingly in this polling showing
this this sense is growing is to get
brexit done I would you know I put my
hand up to be Brett's in second at a
time when we needed compromise
it hasn't been matched by the EU I think
the public now business and ordinary
voters just want the finality of getting
this done on the 20 at the same time I
accept your point that people want it to
be done they want to be over something
that we hear a lot and safe original
something when we go to and parts the
country as well but at the same time
if you're talking about a small
extension to get a deal isn't that
something that most people would say
okay we understand if I'm gonna leave
anyway we'll accept that but is there
any sign from the EU that they would say
okay we need a few extra weeks because
we need to work on this question of the
exit mechanism if Michel Barnier had
come back with something positive the
move might be different with Yasim he's
come back with the very provocative set
of proposals which would effectively put
a wedge between Northern Ireland the
rest of Great Britain that'd be very
damaging for Northern Ireland but it
would have other precedents the rest the
UK that's clearly unacceptable so it
feels to me that we've reached close to
the end of the road but let's see more
proposals could come from the EU in the
next few days but we've reached the
point at which the EU is just insisting
on this very bad deal because it wants
to exercise control over us and not
really allow us to leave the EU and take
the opportunities of leaving the well
let's be crystal clear what would
Therese may have to get back from
Brussels for you to support the deal I
think realistic proposition well I think
the the assurances that were given when
we backed the series of votes which said
to the Prime Minister if you go back to
the EU get legally binding changes to
the withdrawal agreement in particular
deal with this question of the exit
mechanism so that we're not caught in a
regime of laws that we can't control we
can't get out of if we got something
around that I think the moon Barnea also
did tweet about some more assurance
that's been given saying that you
doesn't want it to be something that is
going to be indefinite yes but look some
of those warm words are fine and welcome
but what we need is legally binding
changes that's what Parliament back the
prime minister to go into go say and
that's what in fairness the Attorney
General has been really striving and
working really hard to try and deliver
so let's see there's still time but this
is for the EU to decide now that you
need to work out whether they want where
they've got the pragmatism the
flexibility we chose to leave didn't
trace it we didn't know sure but and
that's why we've got all the compromise
inherent in this deal what we can't do
is be locked into that whole range of
rules from customs rules from economic
rules to tax policy to social regulation
and have no control of it that wouldn't
be faithful to the referendum now I'm
interested in your thoughts a bit about
the future the Conservative Party you've
written about so
ability to orient some of your own kind
of experiences with your father
yes I just wonder if you think that the
concept of party have a bit of an image
problem right now when it comes to
social mobility when it comes to knife
crime for example when it comes to the
divisions over brexit you worried that
you might lose the next election as a
result so I think when you've been in
office for eight years a bit longer now
it's really important to make sure that
you've still got some vision and some
optimism for the future I think the
Conservatives actually doing rather well
in the polls and I think we've got a
great record on the economy to talk
about but we need to do more to show
that we stand up for a vision of the
fair society which would be a compelling
alternative to frankly the sort of
Marxist earlier that jeremy corbyn's
offer offering and so one of the things
I was talking about today is on top of
the enterprise economy what can we do to
make sure kids get whatever their
background get the opportunity to reach
their full potential in life you
actually is the concept of party setting
that vision out now we've done some
great things so if you look at for
example I mean I read to my boys every
morning we do phonics together and if
you look at the phonics revolution that
Michael Gove introduced that's had a big
impact or I think if you look at the
number of kids in schools doing good or
outstanding we've done a great job but
we need to go further particularly one
of the things I've been talking about is
the vocational route apprenticeships
young apprenticeships are 14 to 16 year
olds we're talking about knife crime and
some of the social challenges we've got
actually some of thats related to
truancy we know truancy rates spiked at
14 to 16 so young apprenticeships would
be a great way of captivating the
interest in the curiosity and the
ambition of those kids right the way
through to degree apprenticeships which
is a great opportunity to give
youngsters the opportunity to go to
effectively get a degree but with all
the opportunity that brings in but none
of the debt that traditional
universities engender so I think that
vision is something we need to be
setting out for the future a vision that
could be set out by future Prime
Minister Jess Phillips the Labour MP
gave up we mentioned her interview
earlier very very open interview what
she said actually I think I'll make
quite a good Prime Minister do you think
you'd make a good Prime Minister I'm you
try this every time on the show and I
always appreciate you touting my
credentials but I'm not getting drawn
into any of the leadership stuff I
understand what your name is being drawn
in and here you are writing articles
talking about your family your backstory
your vision for the future I mean you
can see why I've been Jeske journalist
like me would speculate you're never
pesky so if you're but but I've been
talking about the meritocratic society
how we revive social mobility since 2010
I was first elected but I do think right
now we need to be having an an
optimistic vision for the future on the
economy fair deal for consumers and
workers I've been talking about that as
well but also what we do for those
youngsters who may be bright but not
necessarily very bookish how do we give
them the opportunity to fulfill their
full potential and actually the
apprenticeship and their vocational
group is a really powerful route for
them but we've got to do more well trees
may still be prime minister by Christmas
I don't know she said she's going to
step down I think I would like to see
her be able to do that in a way which is
terms of her own choosing
but I think the government has found
itself in precarious situation and
particularly I think if the government
extends article 50 and/or tries to
reverse effectively the bricks it
promises that we've made I think that
situation will get even trickier okay